proud to see your stinky butt stinky
butt cardi b and offset are expecting
baby number two and offset's reaction to
seeing his little one on the sonogram is
the sweetest thing you'll see all day oh
yes honey on monday the grammy winner
shared this clip of her hubby to her
insta story as they waited to see their
doctor
proud to see your stinky butt stinky
butt
about to see your stinky butt so sleepy
and while the migos rapper might have
been sleepy once the doc came in and
offset caught a glimpse of his baby on
the sonogram he was wide awake and
beaming i mean seriously that right
there is the look of one proud dad
of course cardi and offset share a
three-year-old daughter culture and ever
since the 28 year old up rapper revealed
they're expecting baby number two during
her performance at the 2021 bet awards
cardi has given fans an inside look at
her pregnancy i'm about to see
first think about
yeah yeah oh
she shared these maternity snaps on
instagram there's some big big things on
the way big bangs and last month the
grammy winner took to her insta story to
talk all things pregnancy cravings which
for cardi means all the meat
i don't really eat burgers that much i
used to eat a lot of burgers when i was
younger like a teenager in my early 20s
and now i'm back at it again and oh yeah
barbecue sauce barbecue mead grilled
meat is a real fat craving
baby and one thing's for sure pregnancy
hasn't slowed cardi down one bit oh
snappity snap snap back in july when
normani dropped her new track wild side
which features cardi the rapper slayed
in the jaw-dropping music video dancing
in the buff every other day a new wig
new hair come take me out this mu glare
one month later she was back at it
putting her sweet baby bump on full
display in the music video for rumors
her collab with lizzo party ain't
popping no that's the machine nobody
listen they buying them streams they
even posted on blogs
and when it comes to family it seems
cardi has always known she wants a big
one in 2019 the new york native told e.t
she was ready to give culture some
siblings what does it mean to be a
mother
it means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's indescribable
it's like
like
love joy it's a
switch
you know what i'm saying it's like an
automatic smile so it's everything it's
everything so if one brings you this
much joy
would you double the joy
i want to have more kids you do yeah
more kids that sounds like many i mean
you know
how whatever my body could take and i
feel like i can take